you know it's up guys it's Marcus
Brownlee from mkbhd here with another
tutorial on how to render a four by
three video in sixteen by nine HD format
now this particular method is useful
like if you have a 4:3 four by three
shooting camera and you don't mind it
being stretched like I do have an HD
camera camera but if you do want to get
your videos in HD so that your user can
watch it like in the highest quality
then you can use this piece of software
so the link to download this piece of
software MPEG stream clip is in the
description and what we're gonna do is
just do a sample little video for you
using MPEG stream clip so this is what
it looks like when you open it up it's
very simple looking interface we have
three files or four files in order taken
here that we want to render in HD with
MPEG stream clip and also have the
introduction now these are all avi files
so they're all compatible so I'll go to
file open files and this is just very
very simple way of doing it go to the
desktop and in order select the files
that you want to use so the introduction
and the one-two-three-four I hold ctrl
as I select these clips then I hit OK so
now the MPEG stream clip will open up
all these files in HD they're not in HD
but this is obviously a preview you're
getting of the unboxing of those
headphones but I yeah basically all
those clips are in order so now what
we're going to do to render this in HD
what we're gonna do is go to file and
export to mpeg-4 and mpeg-4 is what I
use to get the absolute highest quality
here's a few things we're going to do to
get to the highest quality we're going
to check the D interlaced video button
up by 30 frames per second up by frames
per second select 30 select the 1280 by
720 HDTV 720p option and last but not
least drag the quality slider now this
is different depending on what you want
the quality or the side of the file size
to be like but we all know that h.264 is
the highest quality compression but it's
going to be a really big file size now
yesterday I uploaded a video and it did
get really good
response but it was nine hundred eighty
five megabytes and it took me a good
hour and a half to upload so I'm be wary
of your file size you cannot apply
anything more than a gigabyte I believe
so if you drag this past about eighty
the file size will start getting big so
I'm going to drag this to eighty and
we're gonna do is hit and make mp4 and
go ahead and name it I'm just gonna name
it name and it's what it looks like when
it starts to encode your video in 720p
so you'll see right here I'm not gonna
minimize it but this is the original
window up in the left hand side you'll
have the exporter preview and we can see
it's nice and widescreen it fills up the
entire it'll fill up the whole YouTube
screen in 720p and up here it'll show us
the encoding process how far we are in
our movie the the bitrate exactly how
far we are so it's 1% done obviously I'm
not gonna finish this for the video but
yeah you get the point so I'm gonna hit
stop and yeah that's that's how you
render for three videos in HD so if you
do want to get the the highest quality
out of your videos using not only
Camtasia Studio 6 which I did a video on
but now out of any video that you do
that you do use a non HD camera for if
you want to get an HD now you know how
to do it so yeah if you like this video
go ahead and rate 5 stars I love the
ratings guys keep up the comments this
is really great and I'm yeah subscribe
if you haven't already and a lot more HD
tutorials to come if you do have a
request go ahead and subscribe and
message me through YouTube and I try to
get to you a request video anyway this
has been mkbhd thanks for watching this
one and stay tuned for more peace